so on the program before I've done
several videos sort of analyzing and
dissecting these absolutely ridiculous
and embarrassing very ignorant
interviews that our president has given
and most of those interviews have been a
pretty huge interest to the audience
which is good I mean it's good that when
I do a dissection of an interview and
really go into detail about what is
being implied what is said what is not
said that the sort of broader
circumstances in which these interviews
are taking place it's good that that
does well because it just signals that
the audience is actually interested in
going beyond just the most superficial
stuff that happens in American politics
a lot of those interviews have gotten
500,000 views on YouTube 750,000 some I
think some of those analyses have even
gotten like a million views on YouTube
those all pale in comparison to an oval
office interview that Donald Trump just
gave to ABC News and George
Stephanopoulos that doesn't require
really anything beyond just the most
superficial analysis because at its core
what Donald Trump is saying is that he's
willing to collude with foreign
countries that are interested in helping
him win the 20/20 election Donald Trump
sang to the extent that colluding with
foreign countries is criminal
whether it's conspiracy to collude or
emoluments violations receiving things
of value he's interested in doing that
in 2020 if anybody has dirt on potential
2020 opponents for him and he wouldn't
go to the FBI so let's just kind of back
up and and set this up George
Stephanopoulos asking Donald Trump about
given everything that happened in 2016
if countries came to you in 2020 with
dirt on your opponents what would you do
let's check out the first piece of this
absolutely insane video your son Don jr.
is up before the Senate Intelligence
Committee today and again he was not
charged with anything in retrospect that
way not only wasn't he charged if you
read it with all of the horrible fake
news I mean I was reading that my son
was going to go to jail there's a good
young
and that he was going to go to jail and
then the report comes out and they
didn't even say they weren't even dog
food here going to the FBI when he got
that okay let's put yourself in a
position you're a congressman somebody
comes up and says hey I have information
on your opponent do you call the FBI I
don't think I mean from anyone you do
I've seen a lot of things over my life I
don't think in my whole life I've ever
called the FBI in my whole life I don't
you don't call the FBI you throw
somebody out of your office you do
whatever Gore got a stolen briefing book
he called the FBI well that's different
the stolen briefing but this is under
stuff this is somebody that said we have
information on your opponent Trump's
right the the initial information that
he was offered in the Trump Tower
meeting might not have been stolen but
then he asked Russia to steal
information he's acting like the theft
of the information is relevant but he
asked for information on Hillary and the
DNC to be illegally hacked and stolen
can you obtain those thirty thousand
missing emails you'll be rewarded for it
Russia if you're listening we'll play
that clip later on but let's go back
just a few seconds here in the George
Stephanopoulos interview and pick it
back up well that's different the stolen
briefing book this isn't a stuff this is
somebody that said we have information
on your opponent oh let me call the FBI
give me a break life lesson whatever
your director says that's what should
happen the FBI director is wrong your
campaign this time for added foreigners
if Russia if China if someone else
offers you information on upon it should
they accept it or should they call the
FBI I think maybe you do both I think
you might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear you want that kind of
interference in our elections it's not
an interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I go maybe to the FBI if
I thought there was something wrong but
when somebody comes up with a poor
research right they come up with a poor
research oh let's call the FBI the FBI
doesn't have enough agents to take care
of it
but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen they all do it they always
have and that's the way it is it's
called Oppo research
that's right he would do it again I mean
truly congratulations to George
Stephanopoulos for this interview it a
really good job done by him eliciting
all of the things that we feared most
but sort of anticipated Donald Trump
would say about this even with that
speech pattern have you noticed that
when Donald Trump picks up on a word or
phrase that he likes he'll then use it
repeatedly three or four times in a
minute sometimes in this case Oppo
research it's a very unusual speech
pattern that he has which we have talked
about before and we could get into but
it's popping up here again but to get to
the core of the substance here
understand what is taking place Donald
Trump wants us to believe he didn't
collude in 2016 he didn't know anything
about Russian help for his campaign he
had no idea that Russia wanted him to be
elected president over Hillary Clinton
he's totally innocent in all ways but if
this time around Russia came around with
information form about whoever is going
to be his 2020 opponent he would
absolutely take it and he probably
wouldn't go to the FBI with that nothing
says no collusion with Russia like
admitting that you're open to collusion
with Russia in 2020 and this is why
there have to be consequences because
without them not only does Donald Trump
get away with it in 2016 which he did
and he's going to he actually becomes
emboldened like a little kid and says I
do it in 2020 as well and a conservative
David Frum had some interesting tweets
about this he says this is like a
smoking gun tape of Nixon confessing on
national television David Frum tweeted
quote like the smoking gun tape if Nixon
had confessed on national television to
a network anchor instead of in the
secrecy of the Oval Office to his most
trusted aide immediately after this clip
of the George Stephanopoulos interview
went live the hashtag impeach Trump now
immediately trending on Twitter after
the interview was published but I hate
to break it to you if you see this
interview and you see what Donald Trump
says about 2020 collusion with foreign
countries and you're shocked
you're either not paying attention or
deliberately ignorant because if any of
this is shocking you haven't read the
Moller report because all of this
willingness to engage in this type of
behavior is in the report if you go by
the bar letter and then you see Donald
from say this you might actually
experience a moment of cognitive
dissonance how can it be bar said no
collusion no obstruction everything's
great the problem was the investigation
not Trump's behavior and then you see
Trump say oh I would I would accept
information about my opponents from
foreign countries in 2020 you might see
that as a contradiction if you just read
what's in the Muller report you would
say oh yeah that this fits perfectly
this is exactly what Moeller found
Donald Trump and the people around him
were willing to do and were doing and as
conservative David Frum also added on
Twitter quote anybody still believe that
Don Jr did not pre-clear his Trump Tower
meeting with Russian agents with his
father first I've been saying this from
the get-go
whatever criminality does or doesn't
exist in the Trump Tower meeting with
Natalia vessel nuts kaya that's not at
issue here
the question is we were told that Donald
Trump had no idea that that meeting was
being planned that that meeting was
happening that that meeting took place
until much much later and I said from
the get-go that's not believable there's
no way that that's the truth and once
again Donald Trump's answer here so
clear so concise of course the I would
take the help and I wouldn't tell the
FBI do any of us believe Trump didn't
know that that Trump Tower meeting was
in development before it took place I
don't believe it for a second why is it
that our president is regularly choosing
other countries over ours Trump says he
would have no responsibility if a
foreign country that's outside of our
democratic system comes to him as a
sitting president with dirt on other
candidates that he would have no
responsibility to go to the FBI that his
responsibility would effectively be to
use that information to win rather than
to try to stop the foreign interference
on our elections this is an open
invitation for other countries to now
try to ingratiate themselves
with Trump in this particular way it's
another signal to Russia or to whoever
else that the door is open
Trump wants to hear from you does nobody
understand that what Donald Trump is
saying in this interview with George
Stephanopoulos is effectively the same
thing as when he said this during the
2016 campaign I will tell you this
Russia if you're listening I hope you're
able to find the 30,000 emails that are
missing I think you will probably be
rewarded mightily by our press let's see
if that happens that'll be next this
interview is that all over again with
different vocabulary and Trump as the
sitting president rather than Trump is
merely a candidate the Oval Office is
not secure the 2020 election is
obviously not safe and the psychology
that we have to apply here is child
psychology I've been reading the book
influenced by Robert Cialdini it's a
real classic from 1984 I've never read
it before I'm finally getting around to
it and the elements in the book based on
the influence and child psychology are
very relevant here when a little kid
gets away with something and their
misdeeds go unpunished they become
emboldened not just to repeat those
misdeeds but to take them further and
see how far they can actually get this
is how children behave and incredibly
this is the psychological framework that
we need to apply to Donald Trump George
W Bush was a terrible president I don't
think he was a anything like Donald
Trump though when it comes to we have to
deal with Donald Trump like we deal with
little kids he didn't have to deal with
Donald with George W Bush like you were
dealing with a little kid you had to
deal with them like you were dealing
with a an individual who has weaponized
neoliberalism and a foreign policy for
political gain but you didn't have to
deal with them like you deal with a
little kid in the way that you do with
Donald Trump and that's what we're
dealing with here are we going to allow
all of this to continue with no
consequences I hope the answer is No
unfortunately I believe the answer is
yes and I want to hear from you what do
you think about this just incredible
incredible interview with George
Stephanopoulos let me know follow me on
Twitter and send me a tweet there at D
Pakman the show is also on twitter at
david pakman show